you have a sick sick mind how much are
you willing to pay dad daddy daddy with
sugar i hate fees
i uh i am sam claflin and i am here with
buzzfeed
to read some first tweets
so wish me luck
this one says okay but sam claflin is
literally the definition of a dreamboat
i would disagree with that but i
appreciate the very very kind words i
what is the definition of the dreamboat
a boat that flies through dreams i have
no idea but thank you i think that's a
compliment to the next one sad clapham
is so hot i'd pay to watch him eat a ham
sandwich why ham why not salami you know
or pepperoni sandwich personally a big
fan
of a ham sandwich how much you willing
to pay i too would gladly eat a poisoned
apple if sam claflin would kiss me well
let me tell you kissing me is like
eating a poison apple don't die for me
it's that's ridiculous sam cleveland is
single i'm 100 afraid to eat sugar cubes
mr hunky from district 4. mr hunky you
can call me mr hunky i'll get my kids to
call me that too instead of dad daddy mr
hunky mr hunky from district 4 the whole
title i want to take a nap in sam
claflin's hair not right now you don't
look at it it's an absolute state of
affair
[Music]
like absolute [ __ ] show sam clappling
god bless your butt
are you you know i always get told that
i don't have a butt i don't know what
that means when someone says you don't
have a bum but i have a very short bum
apparently i don't know what that means
but god bless it anyway sam claflin i
want to lick your beers
feel free you know maybe you and the
person who would pay for a ham sandwich
can get together maybe you can lick me
after i eat the ham sandwich in case i'd
drop any mustard or something sam
claflin could run me over with an
18-wheeler and i'd clap
i wouldn't trust me behind the wheel of
an 18-wheeler but i'm grateful for the
clap why would you clap you'd be dead
i'd say i hate stem clapping for making
me feel things even as mycroft
homes it was the task wasn't it it was
my own as well you know pretty pretty
you know between you and the beard lover
i think we got we got we got we got a
right pair i would let sam claflin break
off every one of my toes and reattach
them to my forehead you have a sick sick
mind i hate feasts i hate toes
especially so that just really
really worries me
sam claflin do you mean sex god i have
been known
to be
uh referred to as um
a god of sex i'd eat sam claflin's arse
with a fork again there's not the
portion size there's not much to offer
there feel free to dig in you know if if
i was to offer any part of me it
wouldn't be that but you know if you
want to use a fork as well only use a
four but it's probably only a fork full
if i was in the 65th hunger games i
would let finicko dare kill me you
wouldn't have to let me
i i'd just kill you anyway because i'm
that good when i say i want a sugar
daddy i mean dessert claflin and sam
claflin only right sugar daddy is that
someone is that like do i just pay you
for things i'm not i'm not doing that i
ain't paying you i'm getting people
paying me to you know eat his ham
sandwich so you're going to pay me to be
your sugar daddy daddy with sugar i
would let finico dare
draw me send tweet what what does that
me send tweet with someone speaking this
into a phone and like ordering their
phone to send the tweet i'm not really
finnic oder so
i feel like that that's for someone else
sam clathron is billy dunn in a live
action daisy jones and six
i will be the most submissive and the
most breedable whole well you're looking
at him baby let's breed though i like
being submissive you know why not you
know i'm letting people
lick my beard and watch me eat ham
sandwiches so let's let's uh let's take
it in turns how about that use and abuse
me so that was first tweets with
buzzfeed thank you very much for sending
in your deliciously um
salivating uh
wonderfully
erotic and insightful tweets it's filled
me with nausea and um well a great deal
to think about please go see the movie
book of love it's funny it's clever
there's a lot of love and a lot of me so
if you want to lick my beard if you want
to watch me eat ham sandwiches this is
not the movie for you
but i promise you the sequel will
involve a lot of beard licking so yeah
tune in
[Music]
you